[Music]
have you ever wondered what it would be
like if you met some of your favorite
cartoon characters in real life get
ready to have your mind blown because
some people really don't have to try
hard to look like our favorite
characters don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
checking out ten kids cartoon characters
that were seen in real life donkey from
Shrek the donkey simply named as donkey
from Shrek is easily one of the most
beloved animated characters ever with
his hyperactive personality donkey can
be seen as sometimes naive and annoying
to most people around him but you can't
deny that he's absolutely hilarious and
easily steals almost every scene in the
movie we all have our favorite donkey
moment in Shrek although he's a donkey
it can be quite hard to find that same
hilarious face on an actual animal but
these two special creatures managed to
nail the donkey look you know it's the
stick your tongue out smile wide and
look a bit out there look yes these
donkeys could easily get the roll of the
most popular animated donkey characters
all they need to do now is put on their
Eddie Murphy voice and well learn how to
speak at least one language did you know
that Shrek 5 is in the works and is
expected to play in cinemas by 2020 at
the latest Eddie Murphy along with other
cast members is rumoured to give his
voice the remarkable Shrek character
once again he also said the script is
already finished and according to him
it's excellent which makes us even more
excited well if they ever need human
donkey characters they know which two
they should bring on board him from
Powerpuff Girls it's hard to believe
anyone could look like him everyone's
favorite villain from the Powerpuff
Girls the character itself is so unique
we can't even begin to describe his
amazing looks him has red skin and seems
to wear something that resembles a tutu
around his neck and waist well at least
we think it's a tutu and so does this
next Queen of dressup who decided to
cosplay as him Fifi O'Hara is a former
contestant of the
love show RuPaul's Drag Race and you
might remember her from her sassy
comebacks it includes telling another
contestant to go back to party city
where you belong implying she bought her
costume at a party supply store well it
looks like Fifi came a long way since
RuPaul's Drag Race she seems to have
brought the 90s characters back to life
on her Instagram and her version of him
from the Powerpuff Girls is simply the
best we have yet to find ahem cosplay
that's so well thought out as Fifi's she
really went for it and even put on a
crowd looking cause in the high-heeled
boots if you ever decide to dress up as
him from the Powerpuff Girls make sure
to send us a picture as we'd love to see
it
hula from Moana Moana is one of the most
popular Disney movies of 2016 the story
revolves around the future chief of the
village of Montenegro Otto wants to
explore what's beyond the island even
though her parents refuse to let her go
anywhere near the sea it's a touching
story with a lesson to follow your heart
and your dreams but Moana also has
plenty of cute characters that stayed in
the shadows but still managed to steal a
few scenes by simply being adorable one
of them is puah Mona's pick do you think
this real-life version of the pig looks
anything like Guha he seems to have a
certain level of cuteness and we can't
help to wonder what he's looking at
speaking of puah have you ever wondered
why she was left behind when Moana went
on her adventures fans had pointed out
to a couple of theories that would
explain why pool was only there for a
few minutes during the movie if you
remember all promotional posters for
Moana showed pool on the boat and many
claim he was cut out of the story at the
last minute others claim that the pig
doesn't even exist as no characters
other than Moana ever acknowledge him
could it be nap whoís actually Mona's
imaginary friend
speaking of imaginary friends wait until
you see our next cartoon character and
his look-alike Woody from Toy Story what
he from the Toy Story which was
originally titled you are a toy
an unexpected look-alike it's Bob Saget
who you might also know as Danny Tanner
from the popular show full house Bob
Saget has that look that makes you
wonder where you've seen them before
have you ever put Bob's picture aside
Woody's picture if you do will guarantee
you see some similarities
despite the visual similarities that do
have very different personalities and
Woody's kindness is the opposite from
Bob sometimes raunchy sense of humor
can you imagine what he taking on some
of Bob's slightly inappropriate jokes
speaking of Toy Story did you know that
Tom Hanks his brother Jim is the voice
of Woody dolls Tom is so busy he
sometimes just doesn't have the time to
work on Toy Story games so he uses Jim
instead the creators of the movie
reported that Disney wanted to showcase
more human characters and although Bob
Saget might be a bit too human for this
popular Disney movie he has the honor of
looking like everyone's favorite Toy
Story character Bob Saget previously
lent his voice to animated characters in
movies Madagascar Casper's Scare School
and farce of the Penguins but he could
easily play as Woody from Toy Story
master shifu from Kung Fu Panda who can
forget about the Senior Master who found
a whole lot of inner peace after trading
poop
remember when he decided to introduce a
kung fu level zero on the spot after he
saw PO fail at the training course if
there's one character that has and needs
a lot of thin in his life its Master
Shifu although small Master Shifu is
pretty powerful in fierce he can execute
maximum force with minimum effort and he
can overpower an opponent by just using
his fingers he's like a ninja appearing
when you least expect him and
disappearing with the blink of an eye
would you want to be trained by Master
Shifu if you're a fan of the grumpy cat
you might be able to see Master Shifu in
real life do you see it
there are definite similarities between
the two even though grumpy cat is well a
cat and Master Shifu is a red panda who
would have thought the grumpy cat would
be Master Shifu in real life no wonder
she's so grumpy imagine everything she
has to endure as part of her internet
fame and
it was confirmed that the grumpy cat is
in fact of girl did you know that her
real name is tartar sauce we swear we're
not making this up
come to think of it her unfortunate name
might explain her grumpy look scar from
The Lion King the winter is coming
people you might be familiar with Game
of Thrones character Khal Drogo he's
portrayed by Jason Momoa and he's
definitely one of the characters with a
completely mesmerizing look does it
remind you of someone else a cartoon
character perhaps well many think that
call resembles scar from The Lion King
and we're right there with them we'll
try not to spoil anything for those who
have yet to see the game of Thrones but
here's what you should know about Khal
Drogo fans left marked Khal Drogo as the
ESTJ type of personality from the famous
16 personality test it means that he's
honest and dedicated but has difficulty
expressing his emotion does it sound
like call to you well if not scars
personality along with his looks might
fit him a little better any hardcore
Disney fan would already know this but
do you know scars real name it's
actually a little-known fact that his
name is actually taka this was revealed
in the Lion King 6 new adventure series
and the translation of that name means
dirt and garbage well scars definitely
not dirt and Khal Drogo's considered to
be his look-alike Ned Flanders from The
Simpsons Ned Flanders was one of those
side characters from The Simpsons that
you just can't help but love although he
stopped the funniest character he
usually does have a somewhat significant
presence in the show he's the Simpsons
neighbor and Homer frequently refers to
him as the stupid Flanders but that's
only because he's jealous of Ned's life
in general Ned Flanders has that typical
look of a cartoon dad a heavy upper lip
mustache perfectly combed hair glasses
and a simple outfit with what looks like
an almost permanent collar shirt well it
looks
this guy totally nailed his look but
he's not the only one doesn't Walter
White from Breaking Bad look like Ned
Flanders to once you see it it's very
hard to unsee it the two have completely
different personalities but fans have
fully embraced the theory that Walter
White is in fact Ned Flanders you can
even find some Illustrated series out
there that mash up the two worlds
together
do you want to see something funny this
is how Ned Flanders actor Harry Shearer
really looks like did you know he voiced
over 20 characters in The Simpsons
even though Harry left the show in 2015
it seems like there are a couple of Ned
look-alikes that could play off the Ned
Flanders look if it's ever needed Puss
in Boots from Shrek let's go [ __ ] to
shrek for a bit because believe it or
not you can find a lot of shrek
character look-alikes meet the realized
Puss in Boots
now cats are automatically cute but when
it's a cat with big eyes like this and a
Puss in Boots hat and boots it's even
cuter than usual
listen boots as Shrek sidekick remember
when he's saying live in la vida loca
with donkey and Shrek - come on who
wouldn't want to have a cat like that
even if you're not a cat person you have
to admit that the live version of Puss
in Boots is pretty cute
this popular cat is played by Antonio
Banderas and it was noted that the two
characters share a number of skills
including dancing and combat so if this
real-life kitty isn't the best fit for a
Puss in Boots look-alike we're sure
Antonio Banderas would be the next best
thing so go on tell us in the comments
if you're a cat or a dog person
be honest did this cute Puss in Boots
look-alike make you like cats just a
little bit more than before well wait
until you see how cute the next cartoon
character looks in real life Johnny
Bravo
Johnny Bravo is one of those characters
that you can't help but look
even though they're just a little bit
annoying well they're annoying quite a
lot actually
Johnny Bravo is your typical gym dude
who spends the majority of his time
flirting with women and of course
failing miserably so finding that Johnny
Bravo look-alike shouldn't be that hard
at all and this guy seems to be totally
nailing it with his big muscles dark
glasses and his hair reaching new
heights this gym goer looks like he
could be the real-life Johnny Bravo
although we do hope that this guy has
better luck with the ladies this show is
definitely one of the most bizarre shows
for kids with plenty of humor only
adults will get have you ever noticed
how many innuendos Johnny Bravo has it's
hard to believe the show was created for
children but enough about Johnny Bravo
it's now time for the three final
look-alikes that will make you go oh can
you guess which Disney movie our next
characters belong to it's the movie that
was the fastest to get to 400 million at
the domestic box office
it's a classic that's still loved by
many The Lion King The Lion King is one
of the most popular Disney movies of all
time how could you not love the touching
story of Simba's journey to becoming a
king it's the movie that makes you laugh
cry and everything in between it also
comes with plenty of interesting
characters that make it hard to decide
which ones are our favorites although
you'll never find a true real-life Simba
or Timon these animals come pretty close
check this out it's a real-life Simba
antimony giving each other a cuddle just
like the characters in the movie and
that's not all
we also found these two lions that look
just like Simba and Mufasa while it's
probably just a coincidence it's one of
the cutest coincidences ever the Lion
King was originally titled the king of
the jungle but the creators had to
change the title because they realized
Lions don't actually live in a jungle
there are so many Lion King stories you
probably haven't ever heard before did
you know that the iconic circle of life
intro into the movie was originally
supposed to be heavy with dialogue the
creators were so impressed with the
music they just let it have its moment
to shine just like these accidental The
Lion King look likes who is your
favorite cartoon character of all time
make sure to let us know in the
and give this video a big thumbs up if
you're a fan of cartoons make sure you
check out ten cartoon characters based
on kids in real life see you in the next
video
[Music]